[Música]
[Aplausos]
eu não consigo fazer esse toque não eu
não consigo fazer eu não consigo
eu não consigo fazer esse toque
desculpa gente eu não consigo fazer esse
toque
eu não consigo fazer esse toque é isso
que a minha cabeça também dizendo agora
neste exato momento e ela está me
dizendo isso muito antes de fazer a
inscrição aqui no ted quando meu amigo
me provocou e disse por que você come em
conta sua história
o ted eu disse porque eu não consigo
fazer um toque na minha cabeça
ela é minha dúvida ela vai além
ela diz você vai subir no palco no
tapete vermelho de frente para 100
pessoas e não sei mais quantas
assistindo e você vai dizer meu nome é
luiz e eu tenho depressão crônica na
frente de todo mundo
você vai conseguir falar isso você vai
conseguir contar seu segredo mais
obscuro e mesmo que você contasse que
vai adiantar tanta gente hoje está
falando sobre depressão porque a sua
fala vai ajudar alguém
de que adianta você fazer esse esforço
de que adianta você subir ali e dizer
isso
essa é a minha cabeça falando ela tá
dizendo eu não consigo fazer esse toque
e eu não sei o que vai adiantar eu não
sei quantas pessoas eu vou impactar eu
não sei quantas pessoas estão escutando
em seu impacto das minhas palavras nem
delas mas eu sei que ao longo da minha
vida eu aprendi que a minha cabeça
costuma mentir e ela costuma dizer
coisas que me impedem de ver o mundo
como ele realmente é
é como se fosse um véu um véu de ísis
para quem não conhece a expressão ver
onde isso é algo que maquia ou impede
você de ver a realidade como ela
realmente é
eu vejo o mundo através do véu da
depressão
eu vejo o mundo de uma outra maneira não
é o mundo real como ele realmente é
é o mundo através disso e da mesma
maneira que eu vejo o mundo através
desse véu eu tenho certeza que o mundo
não me ver de verdade também ele não me
viu e quem o que está por trás do véu e
não viu meu rosto ele viu o véu é um véu
de ísis ea vida sobre cível ela é muito
difícil é uma vida onde o sol ilumina a
comida não te apetece
você tem dificuldade para dormir a
insônia pra você tem dificuldade para
concentrar
você tem dificuldade para memorizar o
toque você tem dificuldade pra sair da
cama
você tem dificuldade de fazer coisas
simples né
não importa se você está lendo um livro
se é bom ou ruim e não te dá prazer não
importa se você está sozinho ou
acompanhado
você se sente sempre da mesma forma
não importa se você não consegue ver a
diferença entre o que você realmente é e
o que a cabeça te dizendo o que
prevalece sobre o véu é que você sempre
um monstro
e aí o pior disso tudo o pior sintoma do
transtorno depressivo eu diria que é um
sentimento de falta de sentimento
você não senti absolutamente nada
e quando eu digo não senti absolutamente
nada é claro que eu não estou me
referindo ao fato de que seu cortar o
meu braço agora não vou sentir dor
se eu cair de um prédio quebrou a perna
não vou sentir dor ou se eu passar cinco
dias em como eu não vou sentir fome não
são esses sentimentos que eu estou
dizendo eu me refiro ao fato de que
quando eu ganhei um prêmio na
universidade eu me sentia diferente
quando eu consegui meu primeiro emprego
me sentia diferente
quando me formei me sentia diferente
quando eu fiz amor com a minha namorada
eu se me sentia diferente quando alguém
da minha família morreu eu me sentia
diferente quando eu tentei me matar eu
me sentia diferente
eu não senti nada e o pior disso desse
sentimento de falta de sentimento é que
ele dá margem pra colapso
o momento de crise
tudo começa com um pensamento eu não
consigo fazer esse toque mas ele pode ir
além
vamos pegar por exemplo você vai querer
viver mais 40 anos desse jeito sem
sentir nada
você vai querer viver desse jeito o
resto da sua vida
e aí é um pensamento puxa o outro que
puxa um outro que puxa um outro que liga
o motor e quando você vê
além da tristeza você está sentindo
raiva raiva que está sentindo desse
jeito ea raiva ela leva diretamente para
a ansiedade ea ansiedade ela vai vir
porque você quer que aquilo acabe e
aquilo não passa ea ansiedade aumenta
até o ponto que ela te leva o pânico eo
pânico então te conduz ao desespero
essa é a genealogia da morte é a árvore
genealógica da morte
tudo começa com um pensamento até chegar
no desespero e quando você está no
desespero você não consegue mais fazer o
cálculo racional
é tão estúpido na idéia de se matar não
é sim quando a gente consegue pensar
direito
quando a gente consegue ser racional mas
num momento do desespero você não
consegue mais pensar que você está
sentindo a sua dor
você está sentindo a sua tristeza sua
raiva sociedade seu pânico seu desespero
e você está sentindo uma dor física como
se alguém pegasse a sua costela chegasse
para o lado chegasse seu pulmão para o
outro pegar seu coração e apertasse até
o ponto de ele quase explodiu ea dor é
tanta
mas ela é tanta que às vezes você nem
porque a morrer você quer que a dor pare
e aí você fica sem alternativa que eu
faço pra essa dor pará que eu posso
fazer
então tudo nasce de um pensamento de
dúvida você vai querer mesmo viver mais
40 anos assim elas e 6 dúvida ela joga
ali no meio da sua cabeça um pensamento
desse mas aí você tá nesse processo tão
desesperado que você tem duas opções a
primeira a ir até o banheiro abril o
espelho pegar um pacotinho de cápsula e
pensar assim 67 pílulas devem dar ou
você vai ter o seu armário pega o maior
sinto que você tem da onu em volta do
pescoço e vai até o chuveiro o seu
banheiro e amarra se sinto ali você vai
até a sua garagem
fecha a porta e coloca uma toalha na
porta
ligo carro e senta atrás do escapamento
ou você entra no carro abre a porta da
garagem sai pega br mais próxima que vai
para formosa e começa a acelerar um
pouquinho mais um pouquinho mais
essa é a primeira opção
a segunda opção e você levanta as mãos
para o céu e chora perguntando se não
tem uma segunda opção é a segunda opção
nacional mesma dúvida
só que dessa vez é você quem joga dúvida
em cima da depressão e se você tiver a
depressão e se você não conseguir me
convenci de que não tem saída
e aí você percebe que agora ela está na
sua posição ela está sob a dúvida
e aí você percebe que você através de um
processo de teimosia está começando a
combater a doença da teimosia da
insistência nasce o confronto do
confronto quando isso nasce o desafio de
confrontá la e do desafio vai nascer é
justamente a esperança de você conseguir
vencer e essa é a genealogia da vida
essa é a árvore genealógica da vida e
tudo começa com a dúvida também mas
dessa vez é você quem está colocando
você quem está falando pro véu e se
tiver um mundo depois de você e se eu
conseguir separar essas duas coisas e
você chega nesse momento da esperança
mas você não sabe o que fazer não existe
bala de prata não existe fórmula mágica
e nem remédio mágico também não existiam
eu sei porque eu já tentei de tudo e
você chega nesse momento e você fala
assim agora o que eu vou fazer
bom meu entender isso gira em torno de
uma palavra chamada resistência você
resistir que nasce da teimosia ita e
você tem música você não vai morrer você
vai enfrentar essa doença você vai
enfrentar essa dúvida esse pensamento e
resistir
deprimido é uma coisa muito difícil mas
é possível
hoje eu trabalho em brasília eu gerencio
14 projetos o servidor público
resisti possível não resista
eu sou empreendedor social criador de
uma ong em brasília que hoje atende mais
de 100 mil pessoas e está em quatro
capitais do país
existia possível então resista
eu tenho a minha família eu tenho os
meus gostos e eu tenho a minha casa eu
estou vivo
não resisti é possível então exista
momento é o tema de cyted momento então
é aquela capacidade como joão explicou
de tirar um corpo da inércia ea inércia
é a propriedade que o corpo tem de se
manter em constância que se mantém no
mesmo estado
a depressão é uma inércia porque a gente
vai ficar no mesmo estado
é muito difícil a gente sair dessa
inércia mas assim como a física ensina
que vem o vetor por fora e tinha empurra
e quebra essa inércia da mesma forma é
com essa doença e o meu vetor
no caso dessa força que quebrou a minha
inércia
pelo menos até agora tem sido vocês sim
vocês
e quando eu digo vocês é lógico que
estou me referindo aos meus amigos ea
minha família lá em brasília que foram
essa força na minha inércia capaz de
empurrar e alterar a situação mas eu
estou me referindo aos espíritas que
estão aqui também que me empurraram para
cima desse palco quando a minha mente
estava me dizendo eu não consigo fazer
esse toque e a vocês que estão
assistindo isso aqui requenta no live
stream e todo mundo lá fora que também
sofre de depressão são vocês a força
eu entendo que é difícil falar sobre
depressão porque é um tema que machuca
se não quer ver a pessoa que você mais
gosta pessoa que você ama sofrendo na
sua frente então você diz conversa varre
para debaixo do tapete fingir que não
existe resultado está tudo bem eu
entendo que é difícil porque a gente
também não entendi muito sobre depressão
a gente fala assim que pergunta para um
menino de 10 anos que ele tem que fazer
se ele pegar um resfriado e ele vai te
falar eu tenho que tomar uma canja de
galinha em turnê e eu vou ficar melhor
agora pergunta para um adulto de 30 e
poucos anos três vezes da idade desse
cara que ele faz com o pensamento
obsessivo com rejeição baixa e baixa
auto-estima pouca auto confiança ele não
vai saber falar o que fazer então existe
uma dificuldade informacional é difícil
falar mas a gente pode reaprender a
falar porque o silêncio é que é letal
então eu queria dizer hoje nesse ted que
a maioria das pessoas que se tem alguém
com depressão na família são filhos de
pais mães irmãos e irmãs a pessoa que
está sentada do teu lado
você não sabe é que usa essa máscara e
fingir que isso não não acontece e vai
para debaixo do tapete e às vezes até
com medo da sociedade não entender então
essas pessoas elas não são impotentes
vocês têm a maior potência que você
imagina se não fosse esse vetor na minha
inércia e esse vetor são vocês
o outro o relacionamento entende que
vive no mundo é você se relacionar com
as pessoas que você só compreende a sua
unicidade quando você está em contraste
com a pluralidade do outro que você só
se sente completo quando você está
diante do incompleto do outro
quando você se relaciona você tem uma
potência uma força que não é deste mundo
e essa potência pode salvar vidas
se não fosse essa potência não estava
falando aqui pra vocês hoje
e eu não estou falando que eu não teria
me inscrito não tô falando que eu não
estaria aqui hoje
hoje a gente está sendo chamada sair da
inércia
a gente está sendo chamado a quebrar
nossa própria inércia e eu tô indo além
e convidando vocês a ajudar o outro a
quebrar a inércia do outro a ver a
potência que vocês têm o impacto que
vocês têm na vida do outro porque só
assim só se a gente atuar juntos se a
gente compreender que todo mundo é
imprescindível e que todo mundo precisa
de todo mundo é que a gente pode mudar
as coisas como são e como é que as
coisas são hoje é como se o mundo de
chamar se para correr uma maratona de 42
quilômetros
isso é difícil a gente sabe a gente tem
problema funcional tem problema familiar
a gente tem problema financeiro é uma
maratona
mas se você tivesse que correr essa
maratona com a mochila de 42 quilos que
é a depressão no mundo hoje ele vai
ignorar isso e ele vai provavelmente
dizer você não consegue chegar no final
quando ele devia estar dizendo falta só
mais um quilômetro
falta só mais um pouquinho e quem vai
dizer essas coisas são vocês para as
pessoas que estão do seu lado que podem
ter esse problema
então eu queria convidar vocês a viver
num mundo onde ter problema não tem
problema
o que a gente aceite as imperfeições nos
dos outros e que a gente entenda a
completude que é viver no mundo a partir
do momento que o outro existe então por
mim e pelas pessoas que têm depressão
pela minha feliz pelo meu amigo pedro
pelo meu amigo vitor pelo meu primo
mauro que se enforcou no passado e por
todo mundo aqui eu queria convidar vocês
a sobreviver ea entender isso que ok tem
problema e que tem espaço nesse mundo
pra cada um de nós com cada
singularidade que nós temos sobrevivam
existam porque vale a pena é possível
ver além desse véu e eu estou aqui para
provar isso que a ternura possa nos
guiar brigada
[Aplausos]